عادة ما يكون غسل سيارتك
عملاً روتينيًا ، ولكن هنا في نورثريدج
يحصل الناس على المزيد من عمليات غسيل السيارات أكثر من
اللازم ، وهذا بسبب
شيء لذيذ يتربص بالداخل
يقولون دائمًا ما نقوله عن غسيل السيارات
كيف حدث ما حدث كيف وصلت إلى
هنا  مضحك حقًا لأن لا أحد
يعتقد أننا هنا ، أنا
ليليان وأنا صاحب خبز
وحلويات ليليان ، ونحن موجودون داخل مغسلة سيارات ،
افتتحت ليليان مطعمها
في مغسلة السيارات لسبب واحد بسيط
كانت تعلم أنه  يقع في مغسلة سيارات
سيوفر حركة مرور على الأقدام وبعض
العملاء الجدد عندما تمشي في الطرادات ،
كنت تواجه روائح
أغلفة معطرات الهواء الصغيرة لعجلة القيادة وأدوات تنظيف السيارات الأخرى
ولكنك أيضًا
تواجه رائحة المطبخ الفلبيني المطبوخ في المنزل
الطعام إن الطعام الفلبيني بسيط
ولكنه لذيذ مع الكثير من لحم الخنزير والدجاج
ولحم البقر والأرز بالطبع لا يمكننا
تناول طعامنا بدون الأرز ، فنحن
مشهورون بأجوفنا المجوفة.  أجوف أجوف
يقولون دائمًا أنه أفضل ما في الغرب
يجب أن يموت من أجله
كشخص أكل ثلاثة أجوف مجوفة
في 24 ساعة يمكنني أن أشهد أنه
طعام فلبيني رائع حقًا يتم تجاهله
دوليًا ولكنه يستعد
ليكون الشيء الكبير التالي في  عالم الطهي
في المتوسط في يوم واحد نبيع فيه حوالي 300
جبة ، يعد الطبخ شغفًا حقًا با
نسبة لي ، لأنه إذا لم تكن شغ
فًا بما تف
له فلن تكون قادرًا على النجاح ، فأنا مم
ن جدًا وممتنًا  أن
لديّ فريقي لأنه بدونهم لا
أعتقد أن هذا هو سرّي ، لذا في المرة القادمة
التي تعامل فيها مع غسيل سيارة
يمكنك أن تتفاخر بأكثر من مجرد
معطر جو برائحة الصنوبر ، يمكنك أن
تتفاخر على
طبق فلبيني المعطر من إمبانادا  طعام مضمون لجعل
رائحة سيارتك أفضل من معطر جو صغير على
الإطلاق
[موسيقى]